trop ouvrent tout de suite ce sens
public avec la campagne des législatives
et marine le pen en déplacement à
marseille gaspard flamand dans ce marché
du sud de la france à marinette du côté
de marseille marine le pen est venue
soutenir les 16 candidats du fn aux
élections législatives dans le
département
depuis sa défaite face à emmanuel macron
il ya un mois l'ex candidate à la
présidentielle mènent une campagne
discrète en vue des législatives et
préfère laisser les commandes aux autres
cadres du parti souhaitait mettre mon
énergie dans la présidence du groupe des
députés à l'assemblée nationale ce que
je pense qu'il va y aura des combats qui
sont fondamentaux qu'on peut pas tout
faire à la fois
donc bien sûr je continue à faire de la
politique je continue à me battre mais
je vais essayer de le faire peut-être à
d'autres fins se battre pour ne pas
reproduire le scénario de 2017 qui reste
amer pour la candidate et son parti
marine le pen avait obtenu près de 34%
des voix à la présidentielle qui s'était
ensuite concrétisé par seulement huit
députés à l'assemblée et 13% des
suffrages cette année le rassemblement
national vise plus haut et espère former
un groupe au palais-bourbon 15 députés
sont nécessaires le parti crédité de 21%
au premier tour des législatives
pourrait remporter entre 20 et 45 des
sièges de l'hémicycle le patron par
intérim du parti espère bien plus pour
pouvoir combattre la politique du
gouvernement
donc je dis aux français c'est de votre
responsabilité que de nous donner de la
force pour vous défendre à l'assemblée
nationale ne laissez pas les pleins
pouvoirs à emmanuel macron voyez
l'efficacité que nous avons en étant six
députés sur 577 pourquoi vous voulez
permirent matignon d'opposition première
force d'opposition et 42% second tour
l'élection présidentielle donc
donnez-nous 150 députés c'est-à-dire
quinze fois plus et vous allez voir que
on peut agir pour défendre et protéger
les français le rassemblement national
n'a pas souhaité s'allier avec
reconquête le mouvement d'eric zemmour
un refus d approuvée par près de la
moitié des électeurs de marine le pen
voilà l'actualité politique en menu de
ce premier débat de sens public on
parlera évidemment aussi des premiers
pas nue du gouvernement de la polémique
damien abad et premiers pas du nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale mais
d'abord donc ce que l'on pourrait titrer
comme une chronique d'une défaite
acceptée par le rassemblement national
on en parle avec mes invités béatrice
giblin bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
géographe directrice de la revue
hérodote albert et nous bonsoir
rédacteur en chef du service politique
du figaro
j'accueille également richard vers
l'union soit reconstruit en france pour
le média suisse blick vous publiez la
france contre elle même c'est aux
éditions grasset vous aviez suivi la
ligne de démarcation pour prendre le
pouls de nos concitoyens et lætitia cru
paëllito reis politique bonsoir laetitia
bienvenue à vous aussi que je démarre
donc avec
marine le pen et le rassemblement
national béatrice giblin comment vous
expliquer cette campagne va dire profil
bas
déjà en 2010 est la campagne des
législatives alors qu'elle avait été au
second tour et qu'elle avait fait un
score moins fort mais quand même assez
inattendue avait été une campagne assez
profil bas déjà
c'est un scrutin qui ne leur est pas
favorable et ils le savent c'est à dire
que s'ils font une campagne tambour
battant et qui se retrouvent avec un
tout petit nombre de députés ça va pas
le faire comme disent les jeunes un peu
pas dire que du coup ils vont apparaître
ce sera des sceptiques se serait laissé
entendre qu'ils pouvaient faire mieux à
l'art et est tandis que la
lnh peut-être que bardella ad'entrée de
jeu de 10 toute façon on n'aura pas
beaucoup de députés ce qui a quand même
un peu surpris c'est partir à la
bataille en sachant qu'on va perdre et
que par rapport à l'opération magistral
qu'a réussi quand même mélenchon zadi
1,9 faire cette alliance électorale
totalement inattendue elle se dit que là
toute façon c'est lui qui va emporter le
morceau c'est lui qui aura la la plus
grande de le plus grand nombre de
députés donc elle joue profil bas et je
pense c'est pas forcément stupide c'est
à dire qu'elle a une certaine
finesse d'analysé justement de ne pas
jouer déceptif peut-être tout le monde
commencera à dire à besson quand même
fait cinquante députés ou soixante
députés dont ceux qui seraient ce qui
est peu peut apparaître comme étant
commune en avec 6 effectivement ça sera
une très intéressante
mais quand même albert zeh nous répéter
à longueur d'interviews de toute façon
on gagnera pas c'est forcément des
mobilisateurs pour pour les électeurs
est-ce qu'il ya peut-être aussi un un
désintérêt de marine le pen pour pour
les législatives christo rich man non
non je travaillais pas ça non je pense
parce que elle est passée du la
tentative de dédiabolisation elle y est
presque parvenu à une tentative de
normalisation et pour arriver peut-être
avec un finalement un manque d'ambition
activement et à la volonté de pas de pas
sûr jouer les élections contrairement à
jean luc mélenchon effectivement qui lui
joue la gagne et il ne surjoue même là
dessus en disant qu'il sera premier
ministre qui sera le chef de la
cohabitation
projection est la conscience que toute
façon il n'ya pas elle a compris elle a
anticipé le fait que que la
majorité présidentielle pour l'instant
sera conduite et quel sera ce qu'elle
vise elle s'est effectivement autour de
60 députés pour un chai c'est un chiffre
symbolique c'est qu'il permet la saisine
du conseil constitutionnel sans avoir
besoin d'aller chercher des ajouts
d'autres partis donc ses comptes et
s'est prouvé que elle peut gagner dans
certains comptes dans certaines
circonscriptions donc des miss et mini
présidentielle chaque fois c'est des
combats à 2 à 3 donc est donné l'idée
qu' elle peut être une force
d'opposition et de jouer l'opposition et
ça qu'elle veut donner comme hymne alors
ça fait effectivement au moment là on a
l'impression que ce manque d'ambition je
fais accepter la défaite et lui fait du
fait jouer un rôle mineur mais son sens
on sent sa vision elle est à plus long
terme donc c'est déjà 2027 pour elle
pour berra de bardella ses parents
tandis que discuter un peu plus tard
mais allez-y mairie contenants et donc
il ya là il ya la volonté de donner une
nouvelle une nouvelle dimension au
rassemblement national d'être une vraie
vie les tables force d'opposition à
l'intérieur du parlement pour l'instant
si cette députée donc il n'avait même
pas groupe donc c'était finalement assez
peu audible à l'assemblée alors il
servait reliait ce que vous comparez
finalement là on était sur le terrain
avec marine le pen dans la région de
marseille cette campagne des
législatives avec celle qu'elle a mené
au pour l'élection présidentielle oui
absolument je trouve qu'elle a elle a la
même posture d'ailleurs ils discutent
des mêmes sujets ce qui n'est pas très
aisé mais non mais vous avez vu tout à
l'heure quand elle parle à cette dame du
pouvoir d'achat les les fans mois
difficiles etc je crois qu'elle se
positionne vraiment comme celle qui
écoute les gens et je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'elle va essayer de rester ça
lui bien réussi avec chants présentiel
facile on peut dire elle a perdu mais
avec un très très bon score
néanmoins elle a je trouve deux
difficultés la première c'est son score
face à celui de reconquête et d'eric
zemmour parce qu'il est évident que si
elle si le rassemblement national arrivé
avec un nombre de députés pas très
éloigné de celui de reconquête alors là
ce serait un camouflet et là ce serait
très difficile abîme il compris en
interne pour elle parce qu'à ce moment
là les question se posera à nouveau sur
son leadership et c'est donc là on peut
quand même interroger sa stratégie est
ce que cette stratégie est la bonne pour
faire face à cette offensive qui est
celle de reconquête et la deuxième
question qu est là et qu'elle va devoir
affronter ses s'est mis un joli d'aller
dire aux gens oui c'est difficile les
fans mois mais si elle n'a pas du tout
de moyens parlementaires pour agir elle
devient observatrice de la scène
politique française au fond on est en
train de voir une marine le pen qui se
condamnent en quelque sorte à devenir
une analyse sur les plaques une analyste
part donc sur les plateaux de télévision
elle est en train peut-être deux comment
dirais-je d'entamer une mue politique
parce qu' elle ne pourra pas pesé alors
sauf si elle avait effectivement choisi
de débuter mais ça paraît déjà beaucoup
sauf si elle n'en avait encore plus et
je pense que elle n'a peut-être pas
clarifié elle-même dans sa tête le rôle
qu'elle veut occuper dans les années à
venir et cette campagne le premier alors
on laetitia vous avez analysé les mots
employés par marine le pen dans dans
cette communication poste présidentiel
et les intentions on va dire de
certaines de ses prises de paroles
conclusion il y en a à chaque fois des
intentions thomas et sous couvert de
cette communication mezza voce que vous
décrivez tout 500 grandes tribunes
médiatiques
quand marine le pen prend la parole nous
répond aux journalistes sur le terrain
c'est pour attaquer violemment ses
adversaires à coup de punch line 6 les
façons uppercut exemple le 8 mai après
un repos bien mérité sur l'ol poste
campagne présidentielle elle revient à
hénin-beaumont lance sa campagne pour
les législatives et cible jean luc
mélenchon qui clame sur tous les toits
qu'il sera premier mini
affable de jean luc mélenchon opposant
les manuels macron a peut-être arrêter
maintenant ça a duré quinze jours ça a
fait rire tout le monde la réalité c'est
que jean luc mélenchon a fait élire
emmanuel macron voilà donc ça le
discrédite absolument pour pouvoir se
mettre dans la posture de l'opposant à
emmanuel macron donc ils jouent les fous
du roi
il surjoue l'insolence à l'égard du
président voilà l'expression mélenchon
fou du roi elle a le mérite d'être clair
avec ses exubérances nous fait-elle
comprendre jean luc mélenchon aurait
aidé à l'élection à la réélection des
manuels macro et on entend même elle ne
le dit pas bien sûr évidemment mais on
entend même le mot bouffon pour
qualifier jean luc mélenchon autre
exemple ce lundi soir
vi qui voici alors cette fois c'était à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
dans sa tournée du sud 1 elle vise cette
fois le nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale pap ndiaye
universitaire encore une fois de talent
un
un homme réfléchi
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur les sujets
qu'ils portent
et par conséquent je le vois mal changer
d'avis brutalement je vois mal
brutalement considérer que contrairement
à ce qu'il a pu écrire il n'y a pas de
racisme structurel en france voilà la
réalité c'est qu'il est un indigéniste
entouré d'un d'hygiéniste et que c'est
la république à ça traoré oui c'est une
vive inquiétude et géo mais c'est même
un cauchemar
la république à ça traoré là encore
cette punchline cette petite phrase et
ultra efficace évidemment à travers pap
ndiaye elle vise emmanuel macron qui
serait à ses yeux aurait finalement
tournée vers les partisans de la dige
nisme duo qui sme en n'écartant jean
michel blanquer requis était lui parti
en croisade contre l'islam au gauchisme
et en choisissant sont opposées selon
elle encore une fois un pape ndiaye
alors on pense qu'on veut de ses
attaques sur le fond est bien que
extrêmement caricaturale la méthode de
marine le pen est ultra efficace alors
je vous proposerai de réagir mais tout à
l'heure sur ces attaques et notamment
sur voilà les enjeux de pap ndiaye au
ministère de l'éducation nationale met
ou peut-être un petit coup d'oeil dans
le rétro béatrice giblin sur l'extrême
droite et les lys l'atvs vous avez dit
c'est un scrutin qui ne leur est pas
favorable historiquement surtout sans
alliance elle aurait eu effectivement
une chance d'avoir un beau coup plus
grand nombre de députés si elle l'avait
fait l'alliance avec reconquête enfin à
l'extrême droite la vengeance est un
plat qui se mange froid
on a eu quand même quelques départs qui
ont fait mal
nicolas bay il ya des choses qui sont
très douloureuses et on peut pas passer
comme ça l'eponge bon et je ne crois pas
par rapport à ce que disait richard sur
le fait que la différence de députés
seraient peut-être faible entre les deux
honnêtement je vois pas reconquête dans
ce système électoral dans ce mode de
scrutin
engrangé un nombre de députés
déjà si lui était lu ci lui était lu ça
sera déjà une performance eric zemmour
qui pour l'instant est donné par son
tour qualifié au second tour et au
second tour et pour l'instant et en
respirant ce ne sont que des sondages
bien évidemment ce sont des sondages
mais compte tenu du système électoral
franchement ça va pas être facile
surtout quand même qu'on va avoir une
extension qui va est élevé alors c'est
pas un électorat jeune qui est votre
amour même s'il ya eu génération z pense
pas que ce soit là qu'il fasse ses
meilleurs ses meilleurs scores donc ça
sera plutôt et dans le sud c'est plutôt
un électorat saint tropez d'être
davantage si les marrons 19 versailles
l'a laissé un super bon enfin et c'est
cogolin c'est quand même c'est pas une
pyramide des âges particulièrement
jeunes enfants va être donc qu'il risque
d'avoir un petit mobilisation mais il ya
aussi un électorat fidéliser par le
rassemblement national donc je pense que
pour lui ça va être extrêmement
difficile mais s'il y avait eu alliance
pour ça que ses électeurs la moitié de
ses électeurs regrette qu'il n'y ait pas
alliance com est-ce que vous avez dit
s'il y avait eu alliance alors là
effectivement cédé beaucoup plus
confortable mais laisser des places à
reconquête après ce qui lui a défait
franchement c'était acceptable alors
quel rôle pour marine le pen
effectivement dans l'est dans les
prochains mois dans les prochaines
années peut-elle envisager de se
présenter une quatrième fois l'élection
présidentielle vous propose d'abord de
l'écouté c'était sur bfm
télé ce jeudi 19 mai elle parle de
circonstances exceptionnelles a priori
je ne serai pas candidat sauf
circonstances exceptionnelles je crois
que ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire en
2017 j'avais dit je ne serai pas
candidate si quelqu'un de mieux placé
que moi et mersch et puis quelqu'un de
mieux placé que moi n'a pas émergé et
donc le jour où je me suis le jour où
j'ai constaté cela j'ai dit alors je
serai candidate j'ai toujours fait
preuve de franchise et je continue à le
faire a priori je ne serai pas candidate
voilà albert et nous les circonstances
exceptionnelles bon ben on peut toujours
en trouver c'est pas très compliqué ça
ouvre des portes mais jean-luc mélenchon
n'est pas loin d'être sur la même
position donc a priori pas candidat mais
mes trois petits points albert et nous
est-ce qu'il n'avait pas dit l'un et
l'autre au soir de leur défaite
respective
je n'irai plus je me représente plus ils
l'ont grillé plusieurs fois j'ai quand
même si on l'a même écrit dans le
journal puisqu'on vient des interviews
notamment de marine le pen qui a rappelé
qu'elle ne se présenterait pas en 2001
celle ci elle été battue en demie le
vende un mois et demi on est à un mois
et demi plus tard
donc ça allait sourire mais je crois
qu'il ya dedans chez elle il ya une
volonté quand même malgré tout de passer
la main et l'avait elle avait ça fait
longtemps qu'elle qu'elle en parle 1
pour l'avoir rencontrée plus en
plusieurs fois même en off même en privé
elle dit qu'elle qu'elle a envie de
tourner la page de laisser la place à
quelqu'un d'autre on pense tous à
jean-paul bardella mai et yahia la
volonté d'aller vers quelque chose de
lui laisse la présidence du
rassemblement malgré ça la présention
assemblement nationale prendrait la
présence du groupe si jamais elle en
avait un à l'assemblée donc on voit bien
que elle essaye d'aller d'aller vers
autre chose maintenant
en quatre ans il peut se passer plein de
choses la dernière année en 2000 26 27
ça peut laisser la place quelque chose
on ne sait jamais mais je reviens sur ce
que disait madame mais c'est vrai que le
système électorale des législatives unis
malades de tours fait qu'il doit y avoir
des alliances or elle n'a pas voulu
qu'on crée concrétiser et contracter des
alliances avec notamment reconquête est
ce qui fait que elle et elle n'est pas
assurée du tout d'avoir une
représentation importante et de la
manière qu'on regrette aussi donc mais
sais-tu c'est un choix un choix
stratégique il peut peser pour l'avenir
notamment à servir les jeux revient sur
les mots de marine le pen circonstances
exceptionnelles dire autre chose faire
que si elle
lll continue de dire je ne me
représenterai pas dans dans cinq ans
elle ouvre la voie à une guerre de
succession donc c'est peut-être aussi
pour pour freiner les ardeurs de ses
successeurs potentiels quelques années
sur cette posture qu'est ce que l'on
pense il me semble que la guerre de
succession au sein du rassemblement
national il y en a plus genre
d'embardées l'a semble-t-il est quand
même dans une position de force en plus
il est rentré dans la famille puisque on
sait bien que derrière le rassemblement
national il y à un clan familial qui est
le clan le pen il est si je ne me trompe
pas bon ménage avec lui une fille
également candidat aux législatives donc
neveu par alliance neveu par alliance à
deux ou ne veut tout court 20 de vol
ralliant voilà mais effectivement 9
alliance non je crois que de ce point de
vue elle avait interdit à la nièce qui
court qui pourrait remplacer
de succession au sein du rassemblement
national c'est une guerre de succession
au sein de l'extrême droite mais comme
vous nous dites que c'est un clan
familial qui tient à l'extrême droite en
france cette réalité depuis l'airé
vestissement en terme d'art à cheval
sous le contrôle de jean qui suit la
brillance est beaucoup plus près que moi
mais elle a quand même fait beaucoup
d'erreurs marion maréchal à cette année
a été un peu son année calamiteuse alors
c'est pas grave parce qu'elle est jeune
mais très franchement pour l'instant
elle a perdu en quelque sorte la
dynamique non un mot comme sur manière
marine pennetier revenir sur ce que
disait laetitia à propos des formules
bien moi quand je l'écouté je trouve que
les formules sont bien choisis mais
c'est pas vraiment des punchline elle
elle les a scene pas vraiment de manière
catégorique est forte elle reste quand
même un petit peu en deçà les mots sont
bien trouvés un de la communication et
fait surtout pas souligner quand le
terme est fort en plus omettre une tôle
m elle accuse quand même le coup est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un élément fatigue
personnel et ça rejoint peut-être ce que
vous disiez qui est qui est peut-être
très fort chez elle aujourd'hui et ça
peut passer avec le temps parce que
suffit de les les circonstances
exceptionnelles
de lâcher vraiment mal voir c'est quand
même pas quelque chose de si simple aide
aussi facile que ça est-ce que c'est sa
vie depuis 30 ans voilà et c'est à
l'oral comme ça d'ailleurs de la
politique comme si sa vie ses saisons
mende et au moment c'est comme mélenchon
mélenchon aussi il disait qu'il passait
la main et un peuple et un nom il est un
peu plus par où il a soixante dix ans
mais me lâcher lâcher le pouvoir surtout
quand on voit comment ils l'exercent ça
sera difficile très très difficile alors
le rn on l'a dit a quasiment déjà
accepté même modéliser sa défaite
stratégiquement élections législatives
on l'a évoqué mais que disent les
enquêtes d'opinion alors ça tout de
suite avec
jonathan du prix niel bonsoir
jonathan alors les dernières projections
des descendeurs avec pas mal de grandes
tendances qui commence à se dessiner
absolument on a trois semaines des
législatives
vous en parlez les rapports de force on
a l'impression qu'ils sont en train de
se cristalliser peu à peu et c'est en
tout cas ce que révèle l'enquêté ipsos
auprès steria pour le monde qui a été
sorti hier qui révèle notamment que 75%
des voix et bien elle serait tu as pire
est derrière l'un de ces trois blocs que
vous allez voir à l'écran en tête on
retrouverait ensemble la majorité
présidentielle qui rassemble entre
autres lrm modem ou horizon 28% des voix
ce ca au premier tour viendraient
ensuite la nuque du ps l'union des
partis de gauche avec 27% au coude à
coude dans la marge d'erreur de ce
sondage est enfin troisième d'une sorte
de blogs d'extrême droite ou et rennais
reconquête serait additionnés et eux ils
atteindraient environ 27% des suffrages
on dirait presque aussi une copie
carbone les résultats du premier tour
finalement de l'élection présidentielle
et cette tripartition en tout cas de
l'électorat elle laisse peu de place aux
autres forces politiques et par exemple
l air et udi sont très très à la peine
alors en projection en nombre de sièges
ça donnerait quoi alors on va prendre un
autre institut de sondage harris
interactive vous allez voir cette
modélisation elle donne un hémicycle qui
ressemblerait à ceux ci ensemble données
entre 300 et 330 sièges puis la nuque
qui pourrait atteindre entre 108 et 172
sièges et enfin et rennes 48 à 75 sièges
à noter que chez cet institut de sondage
harris interactive la nuque et donne est
légèrement en tête du scrutin au soir du
premier tour en nombre de voix mais
qu'au second tour le nombre de sièges en
nombre de sièges et n'arrive que
deuxième une des paires d'une
déperdition est liée à plusieurs
facteurs à écouter jean daniel lévy
en termes de dispersion géographique la
nuque ne fait pas les mêmes scores sur
la totalité du territoire il suffit de
réaliser de regarder par le score de
jean luc mélenchon au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle il surperforme
dans un certain nombre de
circonscriptions et dans une autre
circonscription il sous-performe dans
toute une partie par exemple de l'ouest
et donc ça un valet de même la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir des
candidats présents au deuxième tour le
deuxième aspect il y à des phénomènes
qui sont des phénomènes en fait de
mobilisation en faveur du candidat issu
de la majorité présidentielle c'est à
dire on est contre la nuque donc on peut
être amené à voter au deuxième tour pour
le candidat la réplique on marche on est
contre un candidat d'extrême droite ou
d'un candidat proche des répliques est
donc dans ce cas là on peut voter pour
un candidat la réplique en marche voilà
est en tout cas ces précautions il faut
prendre beaucoup de précautions et qu'il
ya trois semaines donc du scrutin et il
ya un certain nombre de faits politiques
de nature à influencer le scrutin qui
n'ont pas été prises en compte dans ce
dans ses enquêtes d'opinion je pense
notamment au nouveau gouvernement ou
alors pourquoi pas la sphère abad il ya
une autre grande inconnue thomas et
c'est toujours la même chose c'est
l'abstention pour plus d'un électeur sur
deux n'était pas allé voter en 2017
hélas pour 2022 ipsos donne un chiffre à
peu près comparable seuls 47% des
personnes interrogées sont sûrs d'aller
voter merci jonathan et on a déjà
expliqué ici le seuil de qualification
au second tour 12 5% des suffrages qui
évidemment gonfle au
même rythme que l'abstention albertine
ou un petit focus dans ce débat sur jean
luc mélenchon quand même il est en train
partiellement en tout cas de réussir son
pari est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il va
peser à l'assemblée nationale comme
jamais dans sa longue histoire politique
même c'est qui et on sera lui-même ne
sera pas présent alors l'ena la peine à
comprendre on est d'accord mais son
groupe son couple mais il sera là oui il
sera la main il faut rappeler que chaque
chaque membre de la nuque baisse wenn
man u aura un groupe individuelle alors
c'est ce que j'avais c'est la capacité à
se dissocier au soir du second tour des
élections alors ils promettent à
l'intergroupe moi je me demande combien
de temps va tenir sa teinte à roubaix
combien de temps maintenir la cohésion
de ce2 ce2 cet ensemble puisque les
socios entre les socialistes qui ont dit
oui à mélenchon pour des raisons
bassement ou purement électoralistes 1
et elle est née fille par exemple la
france a soumises est-ce que ça tiendra
sk tiendront dans
je pense ça tiendra pas longtemps mais
on sait jamais donc ça va être compliqué
là aussi pour avoir une vue générale
globale et jean luc mélenchon n'étant
pas lui-même présent à l'assemblée
nationale il sera pas donc président du
groupe ou de l'intergroupe et alors il
s'appellera s'appellera parce que quand
on a quand on représente malgré tout un
ensemble un ensemble de 120 130 140
députés au effectivement on a on a un
poids que que la france a soumises
n'avait pas encore dans l'assemblée
sortante ça c'est évident mais jean-luc
mélenchon a d'autres ambitions donc
celle de président de celle des tropes
d'être premier ministre donc alors il
reste trois semaines on a été prudent on
le sera jusqu jusque évidemment à la
veille du du scrutin pour l'instant
voilà ce qui se dessine c'est plutôt une
majorité
il ne sera remis sur quoi qu'il arrive
un nom mais bien sûr que si on le voit
bien ses caleçons des stades assis ici
si la nuque poulain du ps obtient la
majorité
à l'assemblée est ce que emmanuel macron
peut avoir un autre choix c'est de là un
peu de la politique fiction comme ça
mais que de choisir jean luc mélenchon
ne pas pas avoir d'autre choix puisque
il peut appeler quelqu'un d'autre mais
la personne qu'il appellerait ne
répondrait pas favorablement il sera
obligé si jamais si jamais jean luc
mélenchon a réussi son pari à être in
israel il serait le premier ministre
mais alors c'est intéressant parce
qu'effectivement il va se jouer à une
question chère wehrli de de leadership
de l'opposition entre marine le pen et
jean luc mélenchon jean luc mélenchon
qui va peser beaucoup plus lourd en
nombre de sièges à l'assemblée tout en
n'étant pas et marine le pen qui va
peser moins lourd tout en y étant cc1
c'est un drôle de match à fronts
renversés moi j'avoue venant d'un pays
parlementaire que je ne comprends pas la
stratégie de jean luc mélenchon
pourcelly j'ai dit je comprends bien
l'alliance la nuit belge je comprends
bien le jeu qu'ils jouent à se présenter
comme premier ministre y compris
d'ailleurs sur les tracts des candidats
jean luc mélenchon premier ministre mais
je ne comprends pas pourquoi il ne se
présente pas il donne aux gens
comprennent pas et d'autant que dans ces
circonscriptions il était semble-t-il
assurés d'être élus celle du vieux port
à marseille mais d'autres
circonscriptions lui aurait été très
favorable parce que de ce fait et s'il
n'est pas nommé premier ministre il est
absent de l'assemblée nationale ou en
revanche il y a de fortes chances que
marine le pen soit présente et eux étant
absente par ailleurs il permet ce que
monsieur disais c'est à dire que les
différents groupes si jean luc mélenchon
et elle a peut-être que les échos vis
des socialistes les communistes se
tiendrait à carreaux et s'il n'est pas
là ça arrive donc je ne comprends pas
alors est ce qu'il y a une botte secrète
peut-être les t-shirts à nous lire une
botte secrète mélenchonistes que nous
n'avons pas vu mais je m'interroge
augmenter ses prêts de la hauteur
d'ailleurs albert me montrer qu'il peut
avant autre chose que le chant
parlementaire d'accord mais le discours
qui a accompagné le fait qu'il ne se
présente pas alors c'était du off on est
d'accord mais c'est sorti partout donc
est-ce que c'est instrumentalisé j'en
sais rien mais c'était bon les voyages
en train ça va bien quoi j'ai changé de
me taper les voyages en utilisation
d'harry marseille ça va je veux dire
c'est catastrophique ce type de discours
c'est à dire que si on sa parfums les
voyages en train et il y en a qui peut
même pas se payer train enfin je veux
dire ils disent qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus
à levante de très très nombreuses années
d'abord sénateurs 7 députés d'accord
t'es rosé en a bien vécu sa souffrance a
commencé à la nettoyer
avant il ya sans doute aussi un
ras-le-bol
de vouloir passer à autre chose oui et
puis y'a quand même le symbole de se
confronter aux électeurs au suffrage
universel
eric zemmour a hésité finalement idée
peut-être sera-t-il battu mais il y va
il ya quinze ministres il avait deux
bornes y compris qu'ils se présentent
eux aussi avec d'ailleurs l'elysée l'a
rappelé à ils quitteront le gouvernement
s'ils perdent c'est normal béatrice
giblin oui mais je serai vraiment mais
creed oui mais juste ça me semble normal
puisque on vient chercher le soufre âge
des citoyens des électeurs et vous le
refuse à partir de ce moment là vous
pouvez difficilement rester premier
ministre ou voir min ça me semble
véritablement là je pense que c'est une
règle c'était sarkozy qu'il l'avait
initié jospin déjà bon alors oui il me
semble très très juste mais je pense que
sur mélenchon alors c'est un terme un
peu qu'on utilise beaucoup mais lien est
un phénomène du bri il se raconte à lui
neige tout il se fait un grand cinéma
vous avez vu les affiches qui sans
régler en immense avec son nom premier
ministre et il ya un petite vignette
avec les candidats pire on n'a quand
même jamais vu ça on associe toujours
marine le pen et le candidat
bon
c'est classique mais là on passe
vraiment sur autre chose et je sais pas
si vous avez vu son trac sur les dix
premiers jours 1 ce qui fait le premier
jour ce qui fait le 3 2 le deuxième jour
ce qui va le troisième jour on n'est pas
si loin de la république c'est moi mais
c'est lui et et avec un racolage sur un
électorat on va dire franco algérien à
200 % au troisième jour on l'enverra du
blé en algérie à un tarif intéressant et
on achètera du pétrole algérien j'essaie
d'une d'une démagogie du passé parce que
j'ai moi moi je trouve ça indigne bon
voilà je le dis carrément je trouve ça
vraiment enfin prendre les électeurs
pour c'est une forme de mépris des faits
commencé tout à l'heure il ya plus rien
au mieux votre analyse en disant quand
même qu'il était en train de réussir un
joli coup politique réussit le coup
politique parce que qu'est-ce qu'on va
avoir allez moi je prends le pari le ps
il aura exactement à peu près le même
nombre de ceux de députés que ce qu'il
avait il alors à entre 25 et 30 les
revendre son âme pour trois députés de
plus que ce qu'on avait en 2017 c'est
quand même cher payé je trouve bien et
pour le les communistes ils iront
peut-être jusqu'à 15 parce que fabien
roussel est en fait une bonne campagne
mais j'en suis pas sûr parce que vous
avez aujourd'hui d'une géographie
électorale très contrastées et c'est le
problème de mélenchon mélenchon on
compte toutes ces voix d'accord mais
quand vous les faites sur
essentiellement deux régions au moment
des circonscriptions électorales
vous pouvez avoue avoir être élu avec 60
% des voix ça vous fait toujours qu'un
seul un social très bon vivement au
deuxième tour il celui qui arrive en
tête il prend la mise et ça explique
aussi le décalage
les intentions de vote au premier tour
et la projection que le ps avec 1,7
pourcentage de voix anne hidalgo aura
peut-être 30 peut-être si c'est éphémère
35 députés parce qu'il a encore une
surface géographique à l'échelle de la
mède showman la métropole qui qui est
importante les indiens qui fier ils ont
identifié le dernier modèle de réussite
le fact cléry sites de la candidature
mélenchon c'est mélenchon lui-même oui
c'est pour ça qu'il est mis en avant
c'est donc sur les sur les tracts
électoraux sur la toute toute la
propagande électorale c'est mélenchon et
donc c'est ce qui fait que
les candidats qui ne sont pas connus
pour la plupart on se réfugie derrière
la figure de mélenchon qui a séduit une
grande partie de la jeunesse on se
rappelait enfin des banlieues donc c'est
sur ces deux c'est la banlieue et la
partie de la jeunesse quand vous
regardez les intentions de vote on me
disait tout à l'heure il ya autour de 47
ou 50% on est à 30 % de votants dans la
seine saint denis
prévu pour cent il le pen exactement le
même problème c'est une bille lisez cet
électorat est donc donc saharidj sudiste
faibli les deux les deux blocs extremis
on va dire ça comme ça j'ouvre un autre
chapitre le dossier damien abad qui
empoisonnent les premiers pas du
gouvernement bornes une réaction pour
commencer celle de xavier bertrand le
président de la région au de france
critique sur le choix de l'exécutif
qui peut imaginer un seul instant que le
président de la république monsieur
macron que la première ministre bandama
bornes ne savait pas quand vous êtes
nommé ministre aujourd'hui vous avez à
la fois une forme d' enquête qui est
menée auprès de la haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie financière de
la vie politique pardon le deuxième
sujet c'est que vous avez également les
impôts qui sont sollicités pour savoir
si ya pas de problèmes dans le dossier
fiscal et la justice est aussi interrogé
pour savoir s'il y a plus à voir ou
autres un moment ou un autre des
plaintes qu'elle soit classée au qu'elle
ne soit pas classé et puis moi je
connais benyamina il y en a forcément
parlé de ce sujet parce que la question
qui est posée c'est est ce qu'il y à
quoi que ce soit qui peut à un moment
donné venir perturber la vie
gouvernementale
il est évident que monsieur macron
madame banon fait ce choix en pleine
connaissance de cause mais albert et
nous on peut on peut rétorquer vous
renvoyé l'argument à xavier bertrand
parce que damien abad soutenait un
soutien aux primaires elle est enfin au
congo à leers et xavier bertrand donc il
aurait donc été surpris s'il avait été
élu président
par les révélations mais oui on peut on
peut être peut être surpris mais dans ce
sens là on peut aussi être très surpris
puisque paraît-il on savait tout le
monde savait ça ait l'air en 2017
christian jacob l'avait même interrogé
sur cette affaire dit on et ils en ont
fait le président du groupe
oui donc la première affaire
avait été classée sans suite aussi mais
aussi ça pour l'instant il n'y a aucune
affaire chiffres deux fois classée sans
suite et l'autre plainte ne veut pas
porter plainte à la justice comme un
bâtard jeunes gros pour l'instant pour
l'instant d'accord voilà mais néanmoins
je trouve ça étonnant et je le rappelle
on a diffusé cet extrait de la réaction
de damien abad hier soir dans cette
émission et conférence de presse depuis
son département de l'ain il clame son
innocence il refuse de démissionner
richard wehrli jusqu'à quand c'est un
peu la question que tout le monde se
pose comment vous vous regardez ça vous
qui avez un peu le recul du
correspondants des médias d'un média
suisse à réussir d'amis avant mon
regarde un peu particulier parce qu'il
est assez connue de la suisse en tout
cas de la semaine passée voilà c'est
frontal les candidats du sucre
conception quasi frontale hier il a
participé d'ailleurs à pas mal
d'instance se vous savez
transfrontalière avec les régions suisse
voisine de la france etc il est connu
comme un bon élu quelqu'un avec lequel
il est très agréable de travailler moi
j'ai passé hier pas mal de coups de fil
dans son département justement et
personne n'est revenu avec des
accusations j'avais je l'avais suivi
dans le passé en campagne électorale et
c1 ce type d'information ne m'étais pas
remonter
cela dit la difficulté c'est celle de
son portefeuille outre le ce qu'il a
commis et et je dirais le la question
qui est posée sur sur son comportement
mais il a un portefeuille qui l'amène à
être en prise directe avec des
intervenants dans ces domaines le
domaine des solidarités le domaine des
violences sociales donc je ne vous dit
cette aide par exemple pas le cas d'un
général d'arm absolument pas je pense
que gerald harlin il était ministre du
budget il a eu des accusations de viol
ou de harcèlement qui elle aussi la
plaignante est apparu comme pas trop
fiable ça a été classée sans suite etc
mais quand il s'occupait du budget il
s'occupait des comptes publics la damien
abad va être en permanence au contact de
gens quand les amis comme secrétaire
d'état marlène schiappa acquis gérald
darmanin oui absolument quand il mais
ça me paraît extrêmement compliqué pour
lui parce que tout ce milieu disons du
social solidarité français est un milieu
qui est particulièrement attentif à ces
questions comment peut-il répondre je
pense quand même que même
psychologiquement son action
gouvernementale aujourd'hui est un peu
entravé et béatrice giblin quand même je
n'arrive pas à voir totalement la
réponse même si j'ai bien compris
qu'elle était là il y avait une prise
politique voilà qui avait cet objectif
mais j'ai quand même du mal à expliquer
le risque pris par pas mma crowe
elizabeth bornes suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous je pense pas que ce
soit exode est bonne qui ait pris le
risque parce que damien abad c'est elle
qui l'a choisi c'est carrément emmanuel
macron essais solaire qui fait le boulot
pour amener à bad clair bon et puis ça
sent maintenant parce que le nerfs il
veut lui faire la peau 1 voilà pendant
cinq ans il est président de groupe il
tape sur le gouvernement pendant cinq
ans et puis retourne sa veste noire bon
donc ses sorties à ce moment là après
c'est à vous
maintenant c'est le ça qui me gêne c'est
qu'il existe quand même quelque chose
mais je ne dis pas qu'il n'existe pas
qu'elle arrêtait de gloser sur le moment
où ça sort alors mehdi lui 2010
elle s'était déjà sorti puis d'accord
on
fait pas de oui oui peut-être vous
demande pêcherait pas de penser que les
petits camarades sont très contentes de
s'occuper sincèrement c'est peut-être
une autre histoire mais dans ce jeu
puisqu'on était son seul jeu politique
oui les principales questions portaient
sur les politiques répondent des dents
dans ce sens bien mais je trouve que
c'est une prise de risque inconsidérée
franchement pour un nouveau gouvernement
avec une femme qu'on met au poste de
premier ministre et avoir s'agirait
toujours un grand classique de mâcon il
n'a pas hésité à renommer dupond moretti
alors même qu'il est mise en examen
c'est pas du tout pour moi je sais bien
danger c'est bien je sais bien non
violent le risque judiciaire n'empêche
pas n'empêche pas non plus venu raconte
de confirmer un michel d'ahmad il a été
confirmé une différence il ya une
différence entre
entre emmanuel macron il avait d'abord
demandé dimanche elle a émis l'idée que
voulait se dégager un petit peu et n'a
pas soutenu
pense à
dania bar quand je dis que c'est pas
elle qui l'avait eu
voix bien qu'il ya peut-être peut-être
qu'en dessous l'analyse essaiera
peut-être un temps de
d'observation la de ce qui est en train
de se passer vers nous le temps
judiciaire il va être
déplacé le tribunal populaire
oui mais un sauve qui détend il est en
marche et si j'ose dire donc si long
calvaire et nous ils ont imaginé
l'exécutif l'elysée observant justement
ce tribunal populaire et voilà se dire
on va finir si on tient ou pas quoi
c'est ce qui va se jouer là ce type
d'affaires ne peut de peu progresser ne
peut se développer que s'il ya de
nouvelles révélations qui arrive si
d'autres plaintes arrivent à essayer
d'autres femmes disaient avoir été
agressée par marc par damien abad
effectivement ça renforcerait encore
mais sinon le la sphère va s'étioler un
petit peu et je pense que l'exécutif
compte un peu là dessus aussi des gars
moment là la machine et médiatique ll
juge rapidement mais elle elle oublie
aussi rapidement donc l'espère il espère
100 m il ya quand même les précédents
n'ont pas darmanin mais nicolas hulot
alors qui est sorti après puisqu'il avec
et bien démissionné comme ça dans un
fracas en disant qu'il n'avait pas les
mains libres et que de toute façon sa
présence était inutile au gouvernement
en sorte entendue librement c'est le
terme qui est temps aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui entendu librement sauf que
là faire les affaires les plusieurs
plaintes à son encontre emmanuel macron
en prend connaissance avant donc vous
voyez bien ils accueillent cela avec on
l'avait entendu cette expression un
silence de marne dont c'était commandes
sérénité de marbre quelque chose qui
était un peu choquant pour un chef de
l'état qui encore une fois fait de la
violence de la dent tout cas d'égalité
homme-femme aider la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes un des axes
de son quinquennat est encore encore
aujourd'hui donc il me semble qu'en
termes d'image c'est intenable en
d'imagerie comme
si on fait comme fi de la présomption
d'innocence
pour l'instant ailleurs prononcé sans
c'est pour ça vous vous souvenez enfin
dans les listes qu'on a vu circuler je
ne sais pas s'il était crédible ou pas
au moment de la formation du
gouvernement un moment donné moi j'avais
vu qu'il était prévu à l'agriculture a
mis à battre son avis des cités je pense
franchement et je ne me prononce pas sur
la la réalité des plaintes et tout ça je
pense que il y a un problème avec ce
ministère c'est quand même le ministère
des solidarités c'est le ministère ou un
sac où on s'adresse aux gens qui
souffrent alors par ailleurs le avec le
handicap c'est le ministère des
souffrances et gérer le ministère des
souffrances quand vous êtes accusé peut
être injustement peut-être à tort
d'avoir fait souffrir quelqu'un il ya
quand même une contradiction dans les
termes